welcome to occasionally awesome of Nicki
Yusuf I'm Kevin Christie did you like
that new intro song you guys hope you
did it came from buddy of Kevin's my
friend Travis Chatham was briefly a man
with my other high school friend West
hopper and he cut up some of the songs
to just put that little instrumental
part that we could use is Anna Lupin our
intro if you want to [ __ ] with Travis's
music he's in a cover band called FM
radio great news yeah I know you were
saying that's weird that someone else
hasn't that was available you can go to
the website it's ww cover band for
higher com they're called FM radio what
was their catchphrase again it was a yes
i dial the styles from all over the
dials know something like that tell me
like it was uh every style from every
dial every step every gal yeah it's
really funny yeah oh that's where that
came from yeah Thank You Travis for
letting us use some music for interest
so we'll probably have this as our music
for a minute a month month in half but
send us uh stuff if you're in a band and
have some music that's not like
copyright protected so that so we don't
have to worry about our episodes being
down if you have something like a on
iTunes ya can't yeah it can't be the
copyright protected pretty much
something they can search for and remove
so if you have something similar to like
what you just heard at the beginning of
this something like fun catchy rock and
roll it could be electronica is rock and
roll inspired whatever something like
that send us what you got and maybe
we'll use it for the next round for the
next you know round of episodes anyway
so yeah Thank You Travis for that and
then what
which day my mind's all over the place
because we're recording this before I
even go to Kentucky but this will come
out after i get bat right so right now
I'm in Las Vegas pretty much as you guys
know listen to this so it's hot we're in
the desert I'm probably by a pool or on
Krispy Kremes in the Excalibur I'm
probably there now actually eating a
doughnut um so I'm playing hair is at
the improv the improv at Harrah's all
week 21st of the 26 Las Vegas Nevada
then the workshop show at The Comedy
Store or july 29th Joe Rogan it
confirmed for that so he will be there
that show Joe Rogan Bobby Lee Kevin
Christy Nick Thune I'm hosting probably
leaving a name out or to that show will
sell out so go to the comedy store's
website five bucks get tickets it'll be
a good show all the comments I just
named doing Brandi material and then San
Antonio the week after that at the LOL
comedy club me and Bobby Lee um and then
this episode was fun that we just did
zapatos episode yeah the what wheat
that's shoes in Spanish oh yeah okay
yeah we talked sneakers with our friend
Jerry Ferrara this is the first
three-time guest panas two guests our
guys to guess yeah we talked sneakers
and being sneaker head and what got you
got him into sneakers what sneakers he
is super into and what about it like why
why we think it's like people get so
fired up about them and where it came
from and it's actually pretty
interesting because I think it has a lot
to do with where you grew up the income
level you grew up who's around and it's
really i think it's like super
environmental that has to do with what
got people into that kind of stuff so it
pretty it's pretty fun yeah what culture
you were coming if you grew up a sports
fan it's like you're gonna know
everything about every sports related to
if you were to skateboarding this issues
that there's um if it's like a weird
interesting thing people get obsessive
it's a big subculture it's actually one
of the bigger subcultures I think right
now in pop culture is sneaker collection
it's a daily thing you can throw on
those shoes every day for months and be
like this is who I am this is what I
think it's basically a thing you can
tell you can say about yourself every
single day which i always find
interesting yeah whenever I get a new
pair of shoes and just like I put them
on and I'm like I'm gonna sit up on a
Ledge and someone's gonna go like this
are cool what are those are you hi me
you hope that they do and then you can
have this whole conversation yeah um but
yeah Jerry does a shitload about Jordans
it's insane it's great because I mean I
learned so much stuff but yeah and then
the nice kicks website so there's a lot
of cocaine there's a lot of cool
information in this episode he tells
some cool stories some fun stories about
growing up about you know press tours
and the fun cool stuff he's gone so you
get a whole range and then you get a lot
of knowledge about Jordans and other
shoes and then some cool like websites
and instagrams to go to to pretty much
see everything that we were talking
about and stay up to date on like what
cool shoes are coming out that's pretty
much that we're not going to give away
any any more details ya have to listen
suckers um okay I think that does it
right yeah okay all right have fun with
this episode that doesn't have a name
yet but it will by the time you click on
one by
like your three-ring get a lot of people
have like back to a lot of teams like go
back to back threes dynasty but it's
when you do three dynasty yeah it's a
dynasty are you talking about the
Cowboys the Bulls like the Yankees have
done like three out of four k3nt same
similarly three out of four sort of
thing the Giants three where the two
they've never gone that Giants not back
to back but like within like a you guys
hate me raise return to a sports bar I
was actually gonna ask you a sports
related question Ling it how many before
you start hating a team you know there's
like a level of like this is a dynasty
these guys are champions they represent
sports an American company like but then
if you get to like five or six you like
and starting at sick of these that
people got sick of the Red Sox after
well like pretty like is like when they
got to like 23 like all right shut up
well cuz the way I in the case of the
Red Sox their whole identity change they
went from a hundred years of a curse
team you ever won a World the Louisville
yeah they just loved wallowing in the
fact that they've never won a World
Series then they won one and people
wearing the shares now I could finally
die happy they went to and then their
identity then became all were the best
now you know yeah well then they could
get like really good players they became
like a great team to go to if you're
like a free agent or whatever right I
just want what I wanted out of the Red
Sox winning constantly talks even is is
like Bill Buckner should have like a
luxury suite never gonna happen should
have like like there should i think they
had him you could share with Steve
Bartman I don't know if they still
waiting for like Kevin James to play
Steve Bartman in the biopic apartments
kind of the only reason I care about
like the Cubs winning is like let that
guy in out of the cold and it's bit well
to answer your question it usually team
wins a championship that's not your
favorite team you're kind of gunning for
them the next year like [ __ ] those guys
two in a row is around the time where it
becomes everyone's on the same side of
do not let them win three in a row
that's where it's like even like teams
that get eliminated like go go beat that
like the Spurs for instance and as well
kinda became that and it's hard to hate
them cuz they're the best run for like
if you look at them as a business
they're the most well
on organization in all of sports yeah
yeah they do it the right way you think
people hate the Spurs because they won
so much because they're kind of boring
both combination of both like right they
win so much they're boring or too
efficient to like a robot a lot of
journalists don't love going to the San
Antonio to cover the finals right you
know they'd much rather go to Miami or
yeah we're hoping the whole thing's kind
of dry they want to be on the riverwalk
cover in the finals in June I say
apparently can smell bad yeah I mean
there's just not a lot of like I guess
personalities like Tony Parker's all
French and whatever Tim Duncan Tim
Duncan his okay guy hustle for like 12
million dollars i don't know if you read
the story know by some shady business
advice and he's not even mad about it
yeah it was a bad decision by me luckily
i have enough mine and now he's also
still like playing for the veteran
minimum like you would think then he'd
try and pull a kobe i'd be like give me
20 million 41 years like my thank you I
still you know still wants to win rings
taking like three million bucks for this
year yeah also they could afford other
players just out there winning champions
that's a championship we're looking like
the lorax is it good did I will tell my
young son if he needed a role model ever
had a young son you look up Tim Duncan
yeah yeah bility even like even the
Admiral was like that they were only
just like quietly great great segue I
love Dave into sneakers yeah do you want
to know why yeah great segue into
sneakers um I so I went and this is not
a plug but I went there's a new shoe
palace open up at Melrose we're talking
about it yeah we got rolling and days
have the what is this oh boy by the way
do you know like do you look at the
colors that you're an artist so I love
that pin I bought it just cuz it was
haulers in the Spurs logo all those
brews logo is that salmon with salmon
when when the Spurs read got a new logo
got a new color scheme in the 90s
basically the entire world bugged out
bugged out you bought that hat just cuz
it was a great looking the first team
that incorporate sort of pinkish yeah
like not masculine masculine color there
before novo had
had we all and that but it would be a
local predates the Lancer yeah they
ushered in a new kind of color scheme
situation well if we're here to talk a
little bit about sneaker so I go to the
the Melrose location of shoe palace and
i'm looking through you know it's
amazing storm looking through the stuff
and sure enough they have the old school
throwback david robinson pumps no one
knows this I mean a lot of people
civilians don't know nike made a pump
before Reba really David Robinson
sneakers had were high top like almost
like how the kobes all I have ever seen
the Kobe hi toxin he plays in like
they're not even high tops they go like
oh like up to the bottom of the knee
almost that's how high they are heard
military but the Admirals kind of had
that level high top and they had a pump
on the side oh yeah with the release
back I remember the first time Billy Cox
in Brooklyn used always make fun of a
CEO ex was a billy cox his mom like
Billy Cox walked out with the neon what
with the white and neon yellow David
Robinson's when they just came out and
he stepped on to this [ __ ] school
yard and he probably reached down I
don't see what is he doing what is he
doing it was gonna fall all day long we
just kept pumping him up and releasing
him up a lot really sins haha Reebok
pumps came out and D Brown and and I had
the michael chang i had the blacktop
pumps I had those new you have a mess of
pumps Nick I think I can't remember if I
actually had a pair when I was a kid or
I just fantasized about them and now
when I look back I'm like I think I had
him right because it sit there and
pom-pom and realities the mic I don't
remember I would buy it they're hard to
find I'd [ __ ] with those right now you
should those are get there ten very hard
to find no be baller if you bought like
14 outside and in 14 cuz you play the
tennis I look him up like once a month
they're not out there they're hard to
but they don't reassure them at all they
did like four years four years ago in a
while they went quickly yeah um the
worst thing in the world to do when you
were a kid with Ponce's it over pump
them and they could actually burst yeah
they could burst like a tire oh yeah
and the white [ __ ] [ __ ] flies
everywhere yes terrible thing to do i
would i would love those michael chang
pumps when's your birthday january
january they only real michael chang
pumps friend they read over this ball
felt they came out in yellow tennis ball
that's how they yeah no but the original
one for the deer is white blue and
yellow the white leather and they had
blue like a blue kind of trim and then
and then and then a yellow tennis ball
pump right there we should one they were
covered in tennis ball felt all the
whole shoes all shoes and i was like
bring it like that is good i wanted to
like a life did a uh an issue uh an
edition of them what if michael chang
was i must have been the first but was
he the only asian athlete to ever have
like a shoe deal i wonder like I don't
know Jeremy Lin ever got one or not he
did he may have been you guys have a
researcher here hey check out if he may
be the first well in America i bet you
there's right now i'm talking about like
yeah I can't do any others in American
how many Asian famous Asian athletes
have there been yeah I mean cuz I would
Michael Chang was he was super young
more like the youngest man to win the
French any his thing was he wasn't like
necessarily the best tennis player he
was incredibly fast so he could get to
the ball really quick he's huge gaps and
he could jump high he was really short
you could jump high and he was
incredibly fast we just got to the ball
quick I need to watch some old michael
chang footage i think dude he was great
that guy was great and talk about like
in high school I was on the tennis team
like that guy meant a lot to the Korean
like Koreans are obsessed with tennis so
like they were there he was everybody's
hero but did you have those sneakers now
I couldn't get my my parents would not
buy me expensive sneakers ever the elite
that when I got pumps is because I had a
job as a busboy I just get a job to be
able to buy expensive George your
Jordans on your kid no no nope I bought
it the only pair of Jordans I've ever
owned i bought when I was like 28 or
like maybe 30 about about white jordan
3s when they were issued a cement 3s you
cement 3s wasn't a bet those are my
favorites negro vault
the black the blackest black cements the
best black cement on uh nice kicks which
I probably one of the best if not the
best like sneaker blog right out there
and they have great what they called
nuts nice kicks ass kicked and they have
uh you know great Instagram account all
that [ __ ] but um what they did like
their 23 obviously not a Jordan like
they're 23 best Jordan threes right and
I'd and black cement with no white
cement was two black cement was one and
it's kind of hard to argue that black
cement to me is the best sneaker where
those winter ever and you could also
wear those with anything and when we
zoom you can wear with a white teeth
they're similar they're similar in it as
to what made what what turned into like
a great throwback jersey is initially
people thought they were ugly when they
first came out I remember my friend
Casey Kelly they undersold yet my friend
Casey canale got a pair and I was like
dough and I just remember being like
those are crazy and but people like oh I
hate him because they didn't like the
cement part yep they were like that's
ugly and then so they undersold which
then it made them into like it's the
same way like the the weird throwback
jerseys are properly like the old white
sox jerseys the old brewers jerseys is
using ugly became those were considered
like really ugly back then yeah they
were cell died and i think i also i
might have been reading this on one of
their blogs or a different blog like
yeah the the white cement 3s and the
black cement 30 just didn't really well
i think that also coincided when they
launched like the spike lee Mars yeah
campaign also like we can't pain worked
in with a success like obviously was no
such thing as viral back then but like
that again a viral video and um yeah
they just didn't sell but the reissue I
guess is similar like even like what
watches like what you know you and I
discussed the milgauss all the time like
yes probably similar thing the mill
gasps did really sell but in a lot of
Rolexes big the most like hot hard to
find ones now are the dogs the Paul
Newman Daytona was a dog ate it it
people didn't what what is that about
our culture is Alexi on the dog in us no
it just makes it less available it just
makes it like people don't save them cuz
they're not popular like
you know combines well yet they don't
make they don't make enough of them they
don't make a lot of them because they're
not popular so then they're not out
there so they makes it hard to find a
popular set a popular anything there's
too many of them because they're they're
easy to find Wow look how ugly that is
nobody has that we have to have that
yeah like it's not hard to find a toyota
camry cuz they're routinely the most
part the same thing in in music like any
artist who just did not release a lot of
[ __ ] or passed away before his or her no
didn't sell anything not a lot of Van
Gogh sold one painting while he was
alive to his brother that's it yeah this
is a lot of right right time wrong place
right time whatever yes it um yeah then
you just don't break to later or design
could be ahead of its time so we could
safely say the jordan the jordan three
was like last man i was ahead of his
time really and you're like that could
that you could come out now like oh my
god it will be like out it wouldn't
think it was throwback you'd be like
that's a good modern what we were just
saying about the Spurs reap redesign it
was black black and grey in the 90s late
80s early nineties the color black and
gray was like outlaw deep cover there
were teams that were there was not that
many teams that work there Tyler scheme
you were tough so the if you think about
the black and gray cement were like they
came out before that [ __ ] and then the
Spurs redo it then look for I think the
White Sox I don't know whose first the
White Sox a Spurs but if you notice
everybody's every rap video from the
every hip-hop video that all there was
white socks hats and Raiders start like
could you imagine white sock hat Raider
starter jacket black cement threes yeah
like you get arrest you could for you're
a turd outlaw a Raiders jacket e star
jackass Raider starter jacket when I was
a kid was a thing I wanted so bad and
was deathly afraid to wear cuz that she
could get you beat the [ __ ] up you're
basically see you're essentially in like
yeah we won't do back yeah you're saying
I'm in a gang so than other gang members
will then ask you will what gang are you
from yeah dr. dre man i know dr. dre
does not need any more praise from me or
anyone else in the world but he could
take full credit for the reason the
relaunch of the white sock logo you can
watch it you can point to a handful of
rappers for
being the reason certain huge companies
have made not millions billions
especially like sports teams yeah as
always rock of whatever spirit become
like a little bit more gangster because
they did the Spurs the White Sox the
Hornets I mean there are certain teams
that benefited from hip hop hugely and I
mean if you want to go back you you can
kind of start with shell toe adidas and
run DMC that's well that's the original
that's like where was a born like if
this was a history with you know we were
taking like a historical tour that would
be the first stop like over here on your
right is uh the first sneaker I remember
wanting it wasn't that it wasn't a shell
toe I wanted uh Pumas I wanted suede
Pumas with fat laces because i watched
Beach Street and all the breakdancers in
them had the the one one side had had
white leather Pumas with a burgundy
stripe and burgundy laces and I was just
like what that is the greatest [ __ ] the
chamber 22 thugged out from it you know
who like I was such a young kid in the
80s there was I'd I was in elementary
school like I was literally like
probably eight years old so there was no
i wasn't i just wanted to fans like all
the cool skate kids and [ __ ] like rock
those fans this is before i skate hurts
checkered vans and all the to those were
like you couldn't look cooler that's
that's what I after this after I was
into breakdancing I started becoming a
skater there was a van store on foothill
and i love that sentence yeah i forgot a
break dancing after right kind of after
I'd you know I hung up to breakdance I
made my mark so I decided to move on but
we would go I would I had to color
checker board vans they were slip-ons
their red white and blue then red
checkers and blue checkers my mom got
him for me at the van store and i just
thought i was just like these are the
coolest to this day I still buy
checkered vans dissuade half cabs when
those came out I'll forget those were
like everyone had those and they were
like the coolest looking break dancers
are kind of like today's surfers I think
in a way like you kind of look at them
like they're usually like tallish skinny
athletic but you don't picture them is
tough but break dances were tough back
in the day oh yeah they and and you have
to be in shape to be able to dance like
that you have wiry strength yes I saw a
lot of good breakdancing fights in the
club when I was like twelve thirty nine
dollars in clubs that's true they were
18 and under night flight she walked
home from there one night four miles to
my house was like the movie warriors
walking through all the bad neighborhood
but that's what made you see that
regularly walked four miles to him from
the club yeah cuz like yeah we're
talking about 1993 how else do you get
home at night dance out here not really
supposed to be out anyway yeah no buses
you could take trains but we I mean I
wasn't really weren't really train kids
we didn't really know you know how the
trains work and you just [ __ ] [ __ ]
his walk will foot it yeah home by foot
but that brings up the scariest thing of
like what made sneakers so attractive to
me was there was a danger element
meaning kids young kids teenagers were
violently robbing yeah jordans really
yeah oh my god yeah like you it was a
sad thing will happen where what
neighborhood did you grow up bensonhurst
brooklyn yeah happen here but you heard
about it on the news and it was always
there and it almost became like that
that really and the first moment of like
oh this shit's kind of dangerous like we
can't i I can't you shouldn't wear the
Jew if we were to jordans tonight flight
and then you had to like walk home at
one o'clock in the morning like someone
might stick you up for your Jordans and
kids were getting robbed for their
sneakers religiously I always found that
such a weird thing to steal because you
would just have to like hope that guy
warrior shoes or whatever well the
theory to was like look if you can't if
you can't wear me something celebrate
and at the time I mean [ __ ] Jordan's
were going for I'll even know they were
a hundred and twenty a thick which crazy
is there really hasn't been that much of
a market like the prices really change I
remember the retros they have four new
lease I'm really changed I remember the
first expensive shoe my mom's
boyfriend's kid his name was Mickey and
he got the nike revolutions and they
were I think a hundred dollars and I
just remember being like I can't believe
a a sneaker cost a hundred dollars and
you tricked your dad into buying
for you my parents laughed at me when I
told them I wanted I was like I want
jordans for Christmas like what are
those a mic michael jordan shoe it's
like you know how much are they like a
hundred dollars i still remember the
conversation I told him that amount they
laughed at me like I was some kind of
[ __ ] and they're like come up with
something else who would ever pay that
much yeah who has that much money to
throw it [ __ ] my father could not wrap
his head around yeah that much money for
something that would wear out that
quickly like your kid their sneakers
they'll be torn to shreds in a month
like three months why would I do that I
find it hard to remember the exact first
pair of expensive shoes I never had
enough many I I know I definitely the
pair the D Brown pumps were the first
like expensive shoe I got and I
definitely had Jorah jordan fours I
don't really remember I think you just
like the word why yeah because I think
that kind of timed out with gonna look
look up uh force report yeah I think I
just oh the red and white there's a
website for people listening called
flight club yeah and you that's a really
easy website to look as if you can just
click on the Georgia yeah you go to my
Air Jordans and you hit on the left side
this all the model numbers it goes
Jordan's one through twenty three or
four it will k was Jordan the were the
force the first nike introduced them
like the kind of mesh uh yes the screen
like this i mean yeah yes uh oh wait
they do them into now and you know a
tues a kind of tues in a weird way which
it have a resurgence like a year ago its
user like not the most fetishize ones
but they're pretty great looking
honestly one's really i didn't ride to
actually like a year or two ago whenever
they did a reagent like i had to go look
up exactly what tues looked like ya nut
date no one bought him in my
neighborhood no they were they were dog
day word they look things looks like no
one's a little bit what the tues or the
force the choose yeah but like look at
him do they look like a jordan to you
now were early jordan they just never
really had like what the thing i think
that keeps the tues relevant is there
some really good jordan images of him
dunking in the shoes he had some really
insane like dunk moments in the twos
yes so did he is the is the free throw
line dunk in twos or threes well you
know threes no threes are the first ones
that have the the silhouette of Jordan
dunking on the tongue right cuz they cuz
hit day before that they said his name
on the back and the NBA made him tick
yes but but the story goes that Nike
would pay the game Nike would pay the
fine right what he would wear them in
the games and night Jordan and and the
NBA said you can't have your name on the
shoe cuz it's like free average and Nike
would play pay the per game fight was
like five grand a game or something jam
the dunk I believe we can choose you can
see there one I think it will once you
get it better i think the silhouette was
probably in one's but i think the free
throw line dunk my is in twos or threes
but yeah i remember cuz yet those double
socks yeah there we go someone has a
[ __ ] picture of him dunking with the
shoes in front of them are those twos
let me see yeah those are three the
three is white threes the free throw
line poster the poster that everyone had
whereas he's just [ __ ] craned his
legs are behind him it's from the free
throw line are white threes have you
guys seen uh ESPN 30 for 30 soul man
about Sonny Vaccaro no but I know he is
you should just watch he's fascinating
he's fascinating um and also where he is
in his life now he kind of like looks
back on it like what did i do i created
a monster but like you know he was kind
of the first one who was getting like
these shoe endorsements for like high
school kids yeah and and you know he
basically helped get jordan and nike and
then he started working for Adidas and
like he had lebron apparent as legend
has it like he had lebron TWP coming out
of high school to sign with adidas
hundred million over like I've been like
seven years or something and then when
he got the contract to take to lebron's
house for like signing day it was like
70 million with the other 30 and
incentives and basically that was it
he'll off went with Nike and the rest is
history but LeBron
I'm could have been adidas it's a great
documentary you know what's so
interesting is no matter how good the
player is if they're not on nike the
shoe doesn't matter look at look at
Shaq's greatness The Shack Reeboks I
don't care they just never mattered
there's some awful big men never really
sold shoes but Shaq is different though
Shaq was the most charismatic big man
ever like post besides Wilt Chamberlain
by here dr. J but here's why it still
matters is because kids who went to the
part after watching the game and then
bought a pair of Jordans or even old
like LeBrons or McGrady or Penny
Hardaway like those are players that
they could actually obviously can't dunk
like Jordan but they could emulate some
of the hint uhi'm crossover like penny
you could try and shoot a fatal edger
you can't back someone down and shatter
a bat there's no school imitation and
that a lot and that's that's the theory
of why big men have never even look
around now what big man has a shoe that
you know about that you're like oh yeah
I gotta go get the new jahlil okafor
Slyke in you know it doesn't I mean do
we do we consider Magic Johnson a big
man those Congress for pretty he was a
point guard 069 but he was a point but
his position yeah no look pass it was no
one wants to go emulate a second apart
right you know in the part you were you
gonna shine like a bat over the Lacey's
up and go Stan was right there my
brother wants to see it assists yeah I
was 5 1 120 pounds Who am I backing down
park right hook shot like I don't you
wanted to emulate that yeah you want to
put on shoes and think you can [ __ ] him
Patrick Ewing's never took off while
you're gonna go wear knee pads let me go
lace up my ua ma where my knee pads I my
friend and I'm Patrick Ewing today be so
cool that came with knee pads my limited
edition you can be pad sold separately
no now today only get the knee pads yeah
Christmas special levy so uh they come
with just foam to shoot that we need to
like shoot like a back in the day video
that
my first time going to New York as ever
I was like 25 I went to New York I
forget why and I i went to you about a
girl no I doesn't know i think i want to
see about a book yeah it to be honest
with you and that's literally the reason
and so i went to new york and i went to
rivington arms the rivington arms a life
store which was a shoes it was cut I
kind of think it was the first of that
curated boats boutique shoe store if it
wasn't it was the only one I knew it was
only sneakers right the door had a
buzzer there was no sign dangerous it
was I i had read about it on like a blog
or seen in the magazine i think i read
about in vice magazine and so i went to
new york i had the address I took a cab
and I went and I buzz in and i bought
the the blue and orange you Patrick
Ewing adidas high tops and then that
night I went out with my friends I drank
the equivalent of a bottle of whiskey
and barf Don him don't get him barf on
your Ewings I did I'm all on your UN's i
barf I don't even you booked on your
friend no I barf on my new sneakers and
it was such a bummer i-i'm you get away
yeah I cleaned him but I was like I'm
ever barfing and mean like ah my shoes
you know who was like a spy remember I
had a poster in my room of Patrick Ewing
dunking in the Ewings yeah like I always
remember too is like sponsored by like
the new york state lottery just never
liked matumbo had a shoe which if we
look at the matumbo now i put him on
Instagram recently like the british
knights no i think they were reebok i
think he had a British night hbu do it
borodin a year and they were the ugliest
can you look up the campaign okay trivia
question for you yes do you remember the
model and name of the car Malone
sneakers oh I've no clue they're
probably called the mailman I feel like
we might have talked about this one last
time I came here to buy gum
[ __ ] it someday like his his his
commercial was like a met with mailman
yet was a mailman I can I remember the
poster remember the company that made
that that sponsor him that made his shoe
I hint in waikele gear was Laila gear LA
gear is correct to this day one of the
cool ahead of its time in the marketing
elegir because it was scientific the LA
gear catapults and in the commercial
like they zoomed inside of the shoe and
literally try to tell us that there was
a catapult like mechanism in the shoe
and I got I had them I might have stolen
I had them thinking that oh my god I'm
gonna be able to dunk like this honestly
like they have this catapult you get
seven inches extra on your vert just
from having the LA gear I remember if i
can find those and i feel like i've seen
them recently and i think i did discuss
them on another rival podcast I gotta
get my hands on some LA gear catapult
work at him there for what was the first
nike that had the visible air pocket
member on the brace the threes had the
air bubble the air bubble yeah 3 says
the first nike that had a refer you to
our seed into the bat the back of the
soul had a likelier window trees and
other thing terrible that like kids
would do in school like Papa Papa yeah
with a pep n to the air bubble into the
air bubble that was that shit's over
that was a dick move leather handle is
the bubbles the the bubbles would
eventually get squeaky what got annoying
when you pop the mule early when you
didn't part when you just all wearing a
while they were just hurt to squeak did
we get anything on that Mutombo oh yeah
sorry um what uh matumbo shoe but what
like what who makes Mutombo like what we
make I think was be having his braces I
thought they were reebok they were red
and yellow and they had like it africa
african print I think it's they look
like a title sequence from in living
color it all says adidas adidas oh [ __ ]
yeah I think they don't look why are you
gonna do as a kid you're 13 years old
you throw on a pair of matumbo zand say
today I'm gonna block shots I love to
kick today I'm gonna be a
I'm gonna be the best rim protector that
guy yeah did he pass away recently or
was it minus pole a very famous still
around he he had a great commercial in
the Super Market blocking shots gone not
in my great- bowl like that this devoted
head like to charity there's like an
urban legend that the first English
Mutombo learned they taught him to come
out I have two games and go who wants to
sex Dikembe I'll no that's your [ __ ]
car race it better be true I hope it's
true if it's not in my mind it'll always
be no what sneaker I will I read that to
me is still one of the best looking is
the Bo Jackson cross train oh god
laughing I in gray black and gray and
they were never not like those things
were cool the minute they came out and
they kind of never went away no what I
they had that front the velcro strap on
the front jizz it said nike and that
[ __ ] was gorgeous there's a period of
time where you couldn't get a shoe
without a [ __ ] velcro strap yeah and
then they came back for like Durant is
big on the straps I had the I don't were
they hoorah cheese they had a right had
a sneaker now I think of it with an
extra weird horrace i love the ho chi
karachi is another like anyone talk
about just comfort like whether the
style is for you or not that's arguably
for you to decide but con a comfort
level hurrah cheese we recently
discussed my end of nike boycott and
last episode i guess is what he's done
yeah we're about you announced it I
don't like it they announced it although
I cuz we advise then hit CNN I admitted
the hypocrisy of tweeting Neil's
commercial to realize that you are in
fact like all of us a brand ambassador
okay yeah so then but a lot so I start
thinking of sneakers like if I was gonna
go out and buy Nikes right now and that
arrived I that her achi man is cool
looking to me but it's a bad crazy weird
colors the like salmon with the [ __ ]
granite yeah the design is really weird
but they're really weird has to be the
most comfortable shoe I thought there
and they dirt that's a shoe you can go
in and find it a foot locker right now a
Glen o galleria there's a her are
everywhere they're everywhere right now
we go to the clinic gallery after or do
you want to go to Melrose shoe policy
was up I mean look guys I swear guy
don't have an endorsement deal that
mention them four times but I do not
have enough there yourself enjoy their
this that we endorse a store all the
time and don't have a deal with them
right yeah I want to go to this place
now do the hora cheese with the rachis
kept they must have come out after the
bo Jackson's but it's that weird gas
trainer type thing where I mean that
well old is that stylish how old is the
hurrah chi Rockies nineties yeah I stay
around for a while I used to play in
those are they a basketball shoe I
didn't even know they had some hi to her
that I think I McGrady ok I think
McGrady was Haro Chi and weber and Chris
Webber I think they just redesigned
there was something because I see him
there always the powers always so much
lately one of the best thing like when
Chris Weber was still in the league i
was i was at a Clippers game when he was
on the Warriors were a rookie who
drafted by the wall was drafted by the
magic and then they traded the rights to
the Warriors for Penny Hardaway who also
like I said I played many pennies at
pennies and imma with the miniature
panda the honey but oil pan Chris Rock
yeah tremendous tremendous tremendous
campaign uh what Chris forever famously
called timeout on accident yes and in
college and I met a Clippers game and
against the Warriors and it's he's
shooting free throws or someone shooting
free throws was very quiet and some guy
in the crowd just goes Chris you've got
two timeouts left just so you know whole
crowd like a lot of the crowd laughs
Chris Webber cracks oh very nice smell
like that's very funny uh what's insane
is I and it it's kind of cool but it's
kind of scary I watched that live I
remember where I was I remember what I
was wearing like I was at my boy Mario's
house calls timeout with no timeout I
was rooting so hard from Michigan I'd
like yeah i just i remember watching the
game seeing that i remember seeing that
in real time going what the fun never
seen that in my life yeah didn't even
know that was a rule most people didn't
know that was a rule and then there's
even like the documentary about it like
if you zoom in like you see his teammate
on the bench putting up the time outside
saying that the bench
was telling him the call timeout yeah
Weber's credit he never really blamed
anyone or like tried to get out of it
and the footage of him going backstage
after the game cuz he was a [ __ ] kid
kid he was a child and I mean that would
all due respect ya 18 years old like he
throwin shares and the cameras of follow
me I get that camera in my face like I
don't know my heart not that my heart
breaks from cuz he everything worked out
for but in that moment in time his world
was over yeah and I actually I like him
as an amenity well I think he's good as
an announcer too yes I got the chance to
uh to meet him when we were doing um
entourage press with the NBA TNT
halftime show which is by far oh it's
the it's one of the high-water marks of
my the worship with muscle on when you
get to the finals you're kind of like
this sucks cookie shut it down together
not as good yeah and Shaq pick this up
at the airport that's amazing where to
God we like landed but this isn't like
humblebrag [ __ ] like we had to take a
private plane or else be physically
would not have been able to do it we
were in New York the moment came up
quick and the reason why I happened so
fast was Aristotle of ubers well like
the Cavs were gonna sweep the Hawks so
it's like and then TNT coverage stops it
was the last TNT broadcast of the season
yeah so it all happened so fast so we we
get off the plane were like walking to
this weird party bus van thing cuz it
was like 28 of us or whatever and
literally walk in and like the vit was
kind of shaking when we walk up to the
van in [ __ ] Shack sitting there with
a camera and just he is fun it was some
there was some I don't know fuse with
the network or whatever it's clearly
some rich dude right came over to say
hello popped his head in shock as
rihanna is that way out and he's changed
it to us like hey I'll a entourage was
awesome like you kissing our ass
bracelet shacks behind him mimicking him
the whole time never met the guy is life
its Jack like going like it yeah that's
grew like an awesome they don't rehearse
they have no idea what there's no script
for those guys those guys turn the
cameras on and say let's go yeah I got
straight Reggie Miller came from behind
I in [ __ ] threw me in a choke rich
miller also ever he knows I hate him
greatest clutch player really I mean
what what is it for what he did to the
next I be another great 34-30 you should
watch and this is not just the sports
that I appoint you may 9.27 second is a
yes it is a human emotion document area
I saw though the UH hunting the Badger
right you see the Reggie Miller one with
like the him and Spike Lee feud yeah and
what he owed to the Knicks and John
Starks who was already a little out
there emotionally he likes set out one
day he's like his goal in the game was
I'm just gonna make I'm gonna get John
Starks don't have a game I'm just going
and sure enough at some point in like a
crucial game to play John Starks got so
mad he [ __ ] leaned in and head-butted
Reggie Miller in the game right Reggie
Miller fell back like oh and they
ejected him there Patrick Ewing and
Anthony Mason and Charles Oakley got so
mad at Starks for getting ejected they
started roughing him up on the court you
gotta watch it well I will net for
netflix Reggie Miller's old man and
Reggie Miller with winning time okay
Reggie Miller's ability to get under
people's skin to me is one of the best
in the league ever him and Dennis Rodman
Dennis Rodman was the Grove people quite
literally nuts yeah didn't start Starks
had some insane dunk over someone like
twice as balls yeah it was it would I
mean I I was like Cartwright or someone
it was over Jordan Pippen and Horace
Grant yeah poor yeah a little one mainly
over Horace Grant but Jordan was in the
shot so it became like what six six feet
no no stocks is 64 65 okay say probably
they hadn't listened at least 63 64 but
calm 64 right there we go so no no he's
big he's he was a big ish yeah to God
back in a but you know Reggie Miller was
67 join 66 so Reggie Miller I mean you
know never had a shoe yeah what would
you call Reggie the Reggie Miller shoe
the blood [ __ ] talker the clutch the
Intimidator but then like note it's so
interesting because he's so clutch but
then like not a championship not with
one finals appearance and
uh you it's so crazy you know Jordan
retired for those two years and it was
and Olajuwon's in the rockets with a
winner but it was a freefall like who's
gonna get these rings while Jordan was
gone yeah there's a lot of people is
like Barkley Ewing blockley you alone uh
Reggie was like it but Reggie was just
really kind of starting into his prime
at that point but there's a lot of
people and in the Rockets gotten both
Jordan had an embargo on championships
the way nike controls mall shoe stores
because then he came back and he be
Barkley and Malone in Stockton twice
yeah and then when turn this into a
sports bike I mean what Jordans are the
ones you're wearing again all these do I
describe them to the audience they are
me and what what do you see a
futuristic-looking their boots the kind
of moon budesh but like athletic patent
leather so the audience right there
should know they are 11 Olympians see
does that mean what I wanted to calm
that the Colombian you know that's what
makes Jordan Sony unique is that there's
a story behind he's one of them okay but
sadly enough i don't really know this
you don't let me his color scheme their
flag I guess oh I think it is that's
what light blue but that's what really
went on to like black and white make
Jordans what they wore is obviously
there was some that were rare and stuff
like that but just like each one of them
has a story a hair here the flood air
jordans is not know what color is the
Colombian flag it's a yellow blue and
red sailing up don't know the story
behind why these are called that oh yeah
well it's if the internet does here
there's a good [ __ ] the post like after
Jordan sixes or sevens that's to me is
where it becomes those ones are
fetishized by only sneakerheads they
have a Jordan for Columbia to with ya so
they kind of go make them for for each
one yeah Oh God when I think Jordans in
light blue I just think like you know
North Carolina well that's the thing
like this is really like the kit like
this is carolina blue that you know yeah
that was in blue total but uh see cuz
you and I are about the same age I go
jordan 1 through 6 is like let like
that's what I try to just wear every day
then in terms of life cuz
life goal yeah look at mina try and get
no one Jordan a day every day of my life
those are the ones that kids were
[ __ ] stealing yeah when I was growing
up putting knives to kids saying like I
run your [ __ ] like give me [ __ ] shoes
like yeah we're breaking into locker
like just if you saw a pair of Jordans
lying around in 1993 didn't Matt you are
gonna go hoos are those you single take
them yeah some 10 some awful human and
this was like a message like stole I
won't name names but stole someone's uh
I think they were threes ya mind is no
force and just tied in together and
threw him on the room over the toe yeah
Telecel and they were hanging there for
you we would throw other shoes out in
the shrine knock them down it was like
the the the game you try to like get a
stuffed animal with the claw we were
trying to knock those four is down how
do you know how big of a ladder would
you have gotten a high up there a fire
truck yet basically we thought about
that too like which one of our like
friends as a relatively firefighter is
that bus the fire hydrant they show up
be like hey while you're here so are
safe suburb version of that at least
knifing it was just going out no one got
stabbed there was no knives no anything
we would go up to each other when we saw
someone had a brand new pair of shoes
and then just step on them yeah it's the
worst thing to do yeah that was like the
really like with this might happen cuz i
don't know i remember a couple of five
you did that to me in the 90s you could
expect the [ __ ] mitts to come at ya I
thought couple people break out in the
like you I mean fights never lasted long
in school they would get program every
minute but what if one of those thugs
kid thought kids had like a nice pair of
adidas or whatever they're always like
white white white white white they kept
them as wide as they could someone would
just walk up and step on him it was just
a Porsche of punch punt and then it
would get broken up I mean the famous
scene and do the right thing guys on it
on of a white guy on his mountain bike
rolls up and and and rolls over the toe
of a guy who's got brand new white
jordan force and he's just like
[ __ ] I mean cuz which there's a
Jordan for by the way they made it they
may Jordans with the do the right thing
colors yeah great I mean there's
something too I mean I think about it in
that
jordans represent like the fanciest
thing you could afford when you don't
come from a lot of money they're under
the status for like it's a hundred bucks
so like you could save up all your get
you know the thing was you got him for
Christmas they were your Christmas gift
what are we considered our age group
without Millennials we're not which
already why what are we know your gen
your leer late Gen X I doubt general
year were you born 77 you're Jenny 9 I
thought in why Millennials are eighteen
nineteen eighty in Tokyo Jack's your
Jenna myogenic jordans for for the gen-x
generation at least for me and where I'm
from was like the first time you learned
at a very young age what financial
bracket your family was in yeah well
like I learned I was poor yeah and I say
poor I mean of the lower income let's
lower to middle you know we had
everything in the world we needed but
only the [ __ ] we needed like I learned
that by knowing that I couldn't get
Jenna wasn't because like you need to
like work and learn the value of dollars
like there's no month it's not there
yeah like so but my mom two things my
mom done and I I almost cry every time I
tell the story cuz it's till this day is
a sweet thing the things i wanted the
most at that age were jordan's and a
starter jacket yeah and I remember going
to the store out for the the starter
jacket i wanted i think back then
starter jackets were like two hundred
dollars right yeah and i went and like i
wanted i want to say i might even throw
in a little bit of a tantrum in the
storm i said i hate being poor some [ __ ]
like that and we just left the store and
this is maybe in like uh early November
so it was close to my birthday and maybe
thought she was trying to trick me and
you're gonna get it for my birthday my
birthday comes around and thanksgiving
no [ __ ] starter jackets and it's
official like okay we're poor I got no
J's I got no starter jacket yeah I had
[ __ ] that's it christmas comes and she
got me i was a rangers starter jacket
what I didn't know was after I threw my
little mini temper tantrums she went
back to the store the next day
a and put the starter jacket on layaway
wake up was paid like dollars a week
yeah for two months and scheduled it out
so by the time christmas came she would
have the starter jacket fully paid off
and that that's great is jet I honestly
I don't I even get stories like that
anymore yes well I are distinct remember
a friend of mine who a away cool parent
no that's one of those things were like
that it shows you when you grow up with
very little it shows you how much your
parents really love you when they do
they go to those lengths and [ __ ] cuz ya
a rich family could have just been like
I want the starter jacket here's a
surgeon and they don't be boiled used to
getting everything you want but what if
when parents go to those lengths when
they don't have a lot is she like hey
yes yes I that jacket I would have
defended that jacket with my life
because I loved it but also just because
like that was my first sign of like a
our situation was a little different
than most families like single mother
kinda stuff and be was the first time I
learned that like that woman is [ __ ]
Superman yeah like I started getting her
father's day cards and you you won in
life yeah I think that's kind of a a
thing we're like a family like a middle
class or lower middle class family it's
like the one thing they would like I
want my kid to feel like every other kid
so it's like yeah we we struggle on some
some things like I know it like a friend
of mine his parents were divorced like
mine and I i want to say they were
probably their income level was probably
slightly lower than mine right her arse
and but he always had Jordans and I
think that was a thing like his dad was
as I think a smart dude about it new
like this matters to the other kids
right now and his kid and his it was a
really good athletes the best baseball
player like our whole Little League like
he was you know great days like this is
get this like matters let slow so it was
like George like Jordans clearly matter
times like let's let's make sure he has
the sneakers that the the kids have so
like he doesn't get made fun of like in
that was like you kind of like I noticed
kids like that was the thing you pics
okay you get to pick one thing you to
pick one next thing it's going to be
those
I think are probably the one nice thing
kids pick even now like a in in in
middle-class families and lower middle
class name is like if you can pick one
thing sneakers you can buy super cheap
clothes you could wear you could go to
like HT away with it you go to H&M and
get a five dollar t-shirt and a fifteen
dollar pair of black jeans and but if
you have Jordans you look [ __ ] cool
web-site a gaudy this with the to stir
jocks there he'll get no jock said four
stripes for I know that yeah I had a
pair of grants wear jocks I had a pair
of white leather jocks I feel like see
like sneakers I guess Jordan's mostly
are like there-there the coolest thing
that own because you get like street
cred with them and their associated with
the coolest people in the world when
you're a kid so like athletes are
amazing they're all heroes they can do
everything that you can and that's one
of the things you aspire to be and it's
an article of clothing you can wear
every day every day and starter jackets
depending on where you live east coast
it's like probably a lot more than what
you've also away with the fat sal's hat
is like the hats fly off a hat or a
after yeah I having had her sneakers you
can wear every day and and and like
clothing you can't get made fun of where
the same thing I the know the the Hat
situation which I and I again I love
hats when I was a kid and I got so stuck
into wearing hats on Entourage I just
tried to stop where I'm one of the few
actors that's more recognizable with a
hat on rightfully so like I try I don't
really wear like I can't wear Yankee had
ever again yeah can I didn't think about
that walking [ __ ] cliche right I do
what I think about Ben Affleck gone girl
yes David Fincher wanted to wear a
Yankees cap and he said it was watching
conflict they shut down production for
for the way I did something similar like
that I shot a commercial for majestic
who made baseball jerseys and right they
like just got the contract bad day
reissuing and read they got the baseball
jersey back so we shot this commercial I
had to wear a dodger stadium at night
right silhouette it in black and they
had like six athletes I was wearing
their jersey and we
me to wear a a matt harvey jersey from
the Mets yeah I said huh can do it they
said well the other option is a red sock
I forget who on the red sock I said well
of it honestly was like a a moment of
like a week long negotiation right yeah
so it ended up being a let me I could
talk about Matt Harvey cuz the spot was
for him but I've still got to wear
Yankee that's the best yeah that's so
great I guess I've reached a sort of
interesting moment my career I could do
that I wasn't for like a truck full of
money or anything right that is so funny
if production will stop because like
that's not my team i can't do it uh I
have a story of why sneakers affected me
physically okay yes yes so while you
know single mom school crossing guard
making ends meet I did have her uncle my
great uncle my grandfather Jerry's
brother uncle Nicky lifetime bachelor
just lifetime just and he had businesses
he had some shady money I'm not gonna
lie i'm not gonna get into the details
of where it came from but he was like
the shoebox under the bed filled with
cash like we'd always go over his house
and just say uncle he could count your
money the red brother would sit there
and he give his i air goin in the bed
get one of the shoe boxes we just count
it we just never took a dollar we just
SAT there and just counting it like and
at the time like 34 grand by my own
millions of dollars to Ilya yeah 30
pairs of jordans so every now and then
if my mom had to like work longer
whenever we were younger like he'd come
scoop us up from school never had
children never married so and of of all
his niece like my grandfather's
grandchildren which was his brother all
girls my brother and I would only boys
and then like say it like seven or eight
nieces great nieces that were his my mom
and her sisters kids he scooped me up
from school in his Zuzu impulse which by
the way back in the day Brooklyn that
little engine made some noise scooped me
up and I was bummed out I was being
dramatic what's wrong yeah what's wrong
I said you know everybody has [ __ ]
you know Dee Brown pumps and I just want
and I play bass I [ __ ] hate plane in
the
and he's like well how much do these go
for I was like nah they're expensive
uncle Nick there they really are let's
go we went to the local [ __ ] foot
locker as I pick out what you ever ones
you want I'm like whoa I got him I
picked out the d brown pumps I got
[ __ ] got home from that and I just
stared at him right next day walk to
school I walked everywhere I went
walking looking at my shoes to the point
where it became a habit and I still do
it to this day when I walk when I'm by
myself you see me walking my heads down
I'm gonna get and I'm walking like this
look at my shoulders bro yeah the good
stover like I am on the fast track to
what's it called scoliosis no that's
what you have to born with you Mormon
well either way I'm on the fast track to
getting a hump in my damn back because I
walk to school every day since that day
looking at my sneakers like this and I
have rounded shoulders and have posture
like this not because I [ __ ] played
the piano or is on the computer too long
because I [ __ ] stared at my sneakers
everywhere I went where I went and those
pumps had a tragic ending I was always
trying to like pull like I'll pump the
tongue I was always trying to pull the
tongue out as far as it can go so I
could like get the genes in there good
yeah i read the tongue out oh I accident
just pulling on it so hard like just to
get it and i get the lace is just
perfect and line up with the with the
pump and just I ripped it out that's the
one thing I used to obsess over is laces
like later they look at they were tied
too tight it looked weird there too yeah
what was up there something geeky about
your laces being too tight you or what
we call the herb you know the harvest a
herb in LA yeah a herb was like our
Brooklyn version of like your your nerd
uh hurt like a loser yeah I feel it was
Bertie the lace lace she's a tire I
don't know why let them things breathe
well I'm joking like that to me like I
can almost pick that with like Larry
Bird's high top converse were like lace
way too tight and then the shoelace the
string was way too long well you look
dumb you we were talking about like the
influence hip hop had and and at certain
athletes had and that's how a lot of hip
hop art like they warm like if they
could have took the laces out they would
have yeah i mean with i remember when i
would get sneakers i would take the
laces out
and then I would lay some backup even if
they weren't fat laces and you had to go
you went you went through the top yeah
jingle under you and goes the top and
you make sure they're in the same order
so like one sides always going over the
other and you keep flat and it almost is
like your hair your braiding them now I
remember this too I won a pair of her ah
cheese in the card game [ __ ] twice the
collar on him from a friend of mine and
then i [ __ ] felt bad and i gave him
back to this is a little bit old I was
like 17 18 like he just get lost so much
money he's like ah Polly brand new
[ __ ] like he had like some neon
yellow and I'm brand new hurrah cheese
we're playing 31 so we played and I was
hot that night I want and I'm like
listen take them back just stop no more
playing and sure enough 10 minutes
ladies like I want back in I'm like well
you can't say i'll put the sneakers back
on i'm like if you [ __ ] lose him
again i'm keeping them he says aren't
and shirt and he lost them again and i
kept them [ __ ] to you had to yeah how
else is he gonna learn with the same
size I mean it's interesting we're
talking about all these sneakers but
like sneaker design that they're kind of
a like a nameless group of designers we
don't know a lot of the names of the
people that design these shoes they
don't get any credit really like you
know you kinda sir like the guy who
designed the nike swoosh like he got
like he worked at Nike so he didn't make
a lot of money yeah that's in Seoul man
dr. yeah hehe I think he got paid eighty
dollars for the logo name the guy the
guy that was something like all a logo
but like the people designing sneak like
we all know the name of like Jeff staple
now right he's a famous like sneaker
customizer in any any any does other
design stuff but like the people that
were designing the bo Jackson the air
the Jordan one all you know the one two
three four five six seven these
unbelievably classic shoes you don't
really know their names are just people
that work at companies and it's sort of
a sheep those enticing people to come
yes yeah it is more their work for hire
like who knows who designed most cars
yeah most I remember the hello kitty
thing when we went to that we know one
really knew who the pros one person that
created a [ __ ] iconic thing that
makes probably billions of dollars
that's kind of like the beauty of it I
don't do you think anyone ever
right when they said any artist ever or
anyone who can't who contracting ours to
do whatever was a sneaker or design for
something that was like this is going to
withstand the test of time I think you
ever know yeah I don't think you know
like whoever drew the Rolling Stones
tongue how the [ __ ] like you think that
person knew the guy who designed that
tattooed on their body years and also it
is probably better for the product
because we better if you want to be
associated with say Jordan or whatever
just Nike or something like you don't
want it to be associated with some like
geeky looking designer guy forever I
think now would be cool if like you know
nike has more money than anybody right
so they like I think it because they put
out like a book like here the people to
design this you know you have a shoe
because then the original drawings
animal eyes that it wasn't nike you
understand like they'll never do that
probably because they I mean they don't
want there's this guy I met last make
Phil Knight famous this guy met last
night goes by name of shoe surgeon right
he can repair sneakers he designed
sneakers yeah I was talking to him a
little bit and I want to get him on my
podcast or you guys should get him on
yours he's a super interesting guy who's
now kind of blowing up and on his best
anela yes and he he did years ago on
Entourage we didn't episode where my
character wanted these custom these
limited air force ones that this artist
pajama play by Rufio played by Rufio one
of the boscoe's but anyway you know we
had undefeated in the show they sold out
we we didn't get in line in time later
in the episode the Vince character pays
20 grand to have the same artist make me
a pair one of one never to be made again
so there was an artist that Nike works
with and they so when we were playing
this episode there are his name is Mark
Smith uh he was going to design the shoe
for the show and and he does all his
design like all his work on the shoes
like he buys a shoe and he has laser
technology that he draws it out and then
he burns it into the leather with a
laser but he wants to interview me like
interview
he was I have to do anything so he
starts asking i am phone interview i
call him up and you start to asking all
these weird not weird but just like
questions are they like what was your
first address growing up who was your
favorite baseball player like all these
little facts that only i would know
about myself and when it came and then
he started asking some I'm like this guy
no it's supposed to be for the character
turtle not for me like he's gonna
provide the wrong [ __ ] you and I don't
have you ever seen the pictures of the
actual shoe I should have brought them
so you guys could see him you've seen it
yeah and there it's kind of like the
vinci code like if i show if I point out
to you the lettering you'll be able to
see it but to the naked eye you can't
see but somewhere on the shoe it says
don mattingly someone's shoe it has my
first address somewhere on the shoe it
literally says mom caught me smoking pot
in 1998 yeah the fault is crazy [ __ ] on
the shoe and um at the time you know it
gets presented me the episode so we made
one for the character and then he made
one for me right one of one so and they
were air force ones at the time so this
guy shoot surgeon at when I'm at two
pals last night for the event comes up
to me and presents me with this box that
says turtle in the same exact lettering
that Mark Smith did and he basically
took that design of all that information
and and their gold by the way the
sneakers were gold and white the
flashiest [ __ ] and he did it in a Jordan
one right spray-painted gold and burned
and it looked it's like exact and the
kids who work at that calm kids they're
teenagers or early 20s who worked in the
store were literally looking at these
things like like Michelangelo's David
yeah they were looking at them like this
is the greatest piece of art those are
for you like on the shoe they were shot
obviously means a lot to me and is
really really cool but I guess in a way
like yet you know these are these are
art like this guy is gonna blow up for
sure if he's not already and Mark Smith
it will never get the recognition that
he kind of deserved for designing those
shoe no one will ever know the name Mark
Smith unless I tell about cuz mike he's
not really interested in blowing him up
yeah I mean it is like a lot of that you
know there's a people collect them like
crazy
see there's a new documentary coming out
about sneakers I I think I'm in it ok
cool not sure to go I was asked to be in
it there's a golf shot something uh
sneakerheads seeker has some it was
something like I'm thinking to the right
thing yes but it is art it is art to the
to the people that are super crazy fans
for it and I kinda like that it is
because the art world is incredibly
alienating yeah it's it's exceptionally
expensive it's it's super super elitist
its most I mean the real the people
buying them art that actually matters
are all billionaire [ __ ] and so I
cut I like that there's like that that
for people who are just let's just say
quote unquote normal people in normal
income level there is like a version of
art you can gets like I can line up I
can get line at undefeated on or
whatever I see them there all the time
last night yeah and I can wait and for
two hundred dollars I can get a thing
that is cool it is unique it is was done
by someone who is artistic it's creative
and to me it is like an art to those
people it is an art also like as a young
kid too cuz sneakers are like really
attractive to like teenagers and kids
about early mid twenties it gives you
something that like belong to and do
what's opportunity to be a part of it
like nerd out on [ __ ] and now that the
first thing my mom my mom did not teach
me like many things about women but she
said like women always look at shoes
first yeah yeah that's like where
woman's I go man it's not necessarily
are you wearing cool Jordans my mom is
just insane about nice my shoe even if
they were like church shoes being clean
yeah shiny no matter how much [ __ ]
money you have you could shine your damn
shoes or like she just likes I don't
know as a woman like my eyes on the may
always go to the [ __ ] like clean shoes
says something about side I you that
you're also identify if I see like kind
of what I think might be a crazy insane
or homeless person like walking on I
can't really tell I always look at the
shoes cosenza get like a newish looking
shirt or whatever but you look down you
like other shoes are beat the [ __ ] cuz
you could drive she was into the ground
Miller has a bit about like the kind
like that's when you know you should be
afraid of somebody like he's like the
Jews a guy like he's like what it's
about how I YP
were afraid of like all black feels like
the only ones you really want to worry
about her like dudes who sneakers are
[ __ ] up he's right some crazy people i
receive white black whatever i always
like have those shoes that are like 10
years too old yeah we know who wears I
does this shady shoe game we should
start worrying about him Mike young
really Mike we start what Mike young
when he comes to play balls playing in
like some Barclays that aren't like
throwback Barclays like the [ __ ] that he
wore in Detroit by playing that are like
a new color like a level of tint from
the Sun that's not normal like Mike
Young shoe game he's starting to go a
boy line on like crazy legarreta he
might be losing it his style but he's
not like the most stylish person if
you've ever noticed he just like it he
does stuff that like just works like a
worry it's like okay you blends you like
Lenny Wright is Dan now or given you'll
really notice and for bad or good style
he just like and he doesn't need to cuz
he's so charming and is always with the
hottest girl imaginable that you look at
why do you need to try and put on extra
cool clothes that Mike Young he's
cloaked in mystery he loved his nap as
fingers and like a nine will grow out of
the [ __ ] ground you both perform
multiple times doing stand-up I know
Mike Young longer than the both of you
have not seen a stand-up you through and
actually get upset sometimes because III
every now like whenever someone's in
town that's always like something i
always want to take them to do is like I
i think the comedy store is cool to go
taken out of town or two so yeah I'll
always ask kevin if he's going up and
like I always end up seeing you there
and let you don't even know sometimes
I've been in the crowd you know we have
not locked eyes looks and I'd like this
weird thing like when I see you hanging
out in the back I don't want to go up
and like I know you don't give a [ __ ]
but I just don't want to like like
starting you gotta get ready and like my
even standing around in the back yeah
like you wait you're always saying on
deck or like getting ready to go and
then like you'll be up there like Mike
Young will come in and they'll be like
yo what's up you can be around like not
do it's already like 1130 I like even
he's like I go on at 145 my Michael
embedded I found a way past midnight I
turned into a [ __ ] gremlin yeah so I
still haven't eaten although I did have
him on my podcast and I played like his
whole state
about them as an apology for being a
terrible critical um I want to ask you
this earlier inside track how many pairs
of shoes do you own and that's right
never you don't want admit I don't know
if I ever won this can't what could i I
really I had a moment where look the
whole freebie culture with especially
with sneakers and but with everything
for actors celebrities never the [ __ ]
you want to call them me you know when I
was younger I didn't understand at first
there was like this moment of like hey
why do you want to give me this shift or
what's the catch what do I owe you you I
got a name my first son nike like I
don't get what's going on then you just
get numb to it like oh no no this is
okay you're like this is allowed they're
gonna give it to someone so I had like a
year or two where like I honestly don't
know I paid for a sneaker or a shirt or
a [ __ ] anything then I had just had
this revelation after like a year or two
of that where it just was just wrong I'm
not saying like it's it's it's not it's
like the worst thing in the world but
like people have become pigs about it
where it's like I we're not gonna give
you a free pair of jordans because
you've been nice and like always talking
about like you're gonna get 10 free pair
i know people listen to this might think
like Oh big [ __ ] problem right now
it's not it's I'm not trying to say it
was a big problem I just at some point
in my mid-20s it became to feel like
this weird gross thing and I just like
that's it yeah its way something's wrong
now that have enough money to buy
sneakers and now I don't have to pay for
them like it doesn't make sense but
weird irony about physics that like I
need more [ __ ] ten years ago man the
more famous you get the letter to pay
for everything it's not so much about
just the fact that you're famous you are
specifically sneaker fame right well on
that level i am yes because of that
episode with the shoe yes and the Air
Force one thing so you kind of are in
the world of sneakers a known as a
person that is also kind of a
sneakerhead right they want like yeah
they want me wearing their sneakers so I
get it like I even though it seemed
wrong to me like I'm getting all this
free [ __ ] in a weird way they were
getting wait to give me a thousand
dollars worth of
acres which is a lot of my my turn the
[ __ ] on a thousand dollars but for them
cost them three not yet 350 like it's
nothing for them it of course is worth
it so I just stopped altogether so there
was a point in time where I had I mean I
had learn more units your laws it once
and it was it was insane right I went
years where I'm talking like I did not
buy a shoe or get a free shy just like
i'm gonna wear what i got until the
treads fall off right and um it wasn't
until recently around the fat sal's
opening time because like we have kind
of incorporated sneakers and Jordans
into like the concept of the stores with
the hats and all that that I started
wearing joins again and the thought was
like first of all I'm not taking a free
anything and I'm not gonna be Precious
about I'm like I'm not gonna stare at
them and some storage unit or some
closet like what it's like the Hope
Diamond I'm gonna wear them as someone
steps on them when I'm gonna wear them
till they're old I'm gonna give them
away I'll gonna donate them and be
really not like a normal [ __ ] person
so now I mean look I do have a couple
hundred pair well I but uh 100 yeah like
your main shoes that you rotate through
you guys a main a couple hundred
anything well I mean if you if you at
one point had storage unit and it's like
a couple hundreds of small chunk Kevin
you know me pretty well at this point
and if you're getting to know me pretty
well I don't have anything extraction
true you don't really have you don't
have it that's like you know Kevin's got
me into watches you're not really a car
guy you refuse to spend any real amount
of money on watches it bothers me a lot
I have some nice watches but luckily my
watch game is not know any different
like is a very very normal guy watch
conservative watch game you're not like
a car dude you don't you don't live in a
mansion like you don't spend money on
basically anything I got lucky the
things that I enjoy are not like the
most accountant loves me Elvis favorite
client it's not even it may be partly
luck but partly because you had like a a
humble working class upbringing it
definitely has something to do with it
uh it's a combination of that
and.and luck like the things I like to
do just don't happen the collect going
to the comedy store with right usually
first of all want you to hook me up so I
don't really ever paper media like take
in like five six people economies were
spent on a box or two like I'm not
saying that's nothing but like that's
not considered expensive habit no in the
way you're almost like my my girls give
me a heart like making fun makes a noise
yammering about like a reissue
skateboard deck and I'm like I'd seen on
I don't need it but she's like well how
much they cost like seventy dollars
she's like what it's not any like you
should be so lucky to fetishize
something that uh uh in expensive in
comparison to things you could be relics
in your it look if it's all relative to
your income base like it really I I yeah
I mean I like cars I have a nice car but
I just downgraded to a lesser payment
like I don't run I don't know I'm just I
got lucky in that way I don't have crazy
expensive I'll have [ __ ] ten thousand
dollar suits and oh that's the dumbest
well I got a haircut once a week that's
one of my biggest expenses that i wish i
could do that once a week I try to keep
the fro trim to open soon week i do once
every five weeks really I see you got
kind of fresh-cut ride yesterday so what
is that what happens to that in five
weeks it just turns like normal its I
don't ever listen notice it looking that
super different because you pre put
together never been like Oh Nick needs a
haircut yeah I've never let it get to
that point but five weeks that's pretty
life I gotta for me five weeks man a lot
because he cuts it so so tight that five
weeks just looks like it's like a
regular haircut yeah you know I mean
tonight that's I do that on purpose
because it just gets annoying some like
just [ __ ] every and he doesn't charge
a lot it's like a once a week like one
of my buddies just moved here from
Brooklyn and uh you know he was as he's
I will you know who's your barber I need
a barber and I I have had the same
barber for years now and he look I guess
in the barbershop world he's expecting
charges like 40 bucks and then tip
that's like a that that's a healthy
amount of money for a cut when I told
him that he's I can't use on my wives I
cuz he like goes like twice a week yeah
so I'm like twice away
Oh thatthat see but in Brooklyn it's
like it starts from the feet up so like
it starts at the sneakers and whatever
like whether you're in shape or not
whatever your tattoos are and it ends at
the head what your cut is that's like
Oakland fashion 101 sneakers tattoos and
in your hair Wow number I may be doing
that you do well in bro old-school
Brooklyn New and new-school broken but
you even fit in an old Brooklyn remember
once Dame Dash was talking about like
meeting Jay Z and how he was skeptical
because day Mike think was from Harlem
and JV her Jay was jay-z was from
Brooklyn and i was like he showed up he
was wearing Nikes not feel us but it's
kind of like clowning him like you know
he showed up he looked right yeah like
the right shoes on vlo in even touch
upon feel there's a kind of a certain
kind of Mila that is kind of so wrong
it's right where you're like it makes
you remind you of like salt and pepper
and some like those jackets fila in the
Brooklyn Italian community yeah tell you
look at the Guido community true sergio
tacchini suit another suit the sweat
suit we have it like that's like
gangster 101 right in monsters look like
in the 80 s and 90 PS save kota kinabalu
off with a pair of [ __ ] feel is a
black suede feel is on your field that
was the definition of and i guess in a
weird way in new york in Brooklyn young
like 80's 90's gangsters I mean like
Italian mobsters own house yeah also
contributed to the sneaker game cuz that
like I said starts from the feet up and
um they were the fart like filas they
even started wearing short like the the
shoe game to them was very important and
old-school gangsters even like in the
gaudy era god John Gotti was a fashion
icon yeah John Gotti was a fashion yeah
burgundy felis wetsuit Oh with the it
white or black suede you're like watch
out for that shea that's how popular it
was like yeah on the suppress everything
stir like stereotype is felis wetsuit
sergio tacchini sweat suit rather right
yeah right what do you think about
collaboration shoes but you ever get
into that because that's like a sub
obsession of
sneakerheads where certain companies
like collaborate you're like like like
James and Disney are doing that Puma has
been doing it these the Jeff staple gone
is the Jeff stapled up with the pigeon I
did for me it's here miss rare it could
be so sweet and so well done and then as
our times which is kinda seems a little
corny I just hit a Miss like for what
for me that you write did those older
ones are of that that that that people
that just live for that what's the air
jordan 1 over it the new jordan one just
came out with the orange it's a it's
it's edition that's not a collaboration
i used for for Russell Westbrook now I
don't remember it doesn't matter I was
you talking about me sorry well made you
may get up on your game buddy what do
you guys think about like what Kanye is
done for adidas has they say what you
want the [ __ ] we were the most recent
ones that came adidas has always been
like they're all with you know they're
kind of the number two and they're
always like butting up against Nikes
relevant some real interesting shiny a
real interesting looking I don't see a
ton of people wearing out a backboard
and I don't I wonder if there's is it
III would doubt you could really even
[ __ ] with nike's market share at this
point no no but on a worldwide level
though I think adidas is bigger cuz a
soccer there's a place for adidas like
adidas has but I think you're about in
Europe adidas is much more popular the
easy boost 350 the light there so
bizarre look they I mean they sold out
and did you ever get the the the the cut
the nike Kanye's did not ever have those
I never I like those I thought they were
cool looking yeah I am I never ever like
gotten into because he's not an athlete
yeah yeah and everything i'm not saying
i'm right about it I just this is my
preference like I don't you know I like
the mixture of wearing something that
was once used for athletics yeah
incorporating them into like your casual
fashion that's been like the whole I
think there's something cuz because
jordan i think is in arguably the
greatest basketball player of all-time
agreed people will log you but i agree I
mean who's who do you put
there's so many deer people some people
will put Bill Russell because of his
champion Joe Russell yeah mad like I
kind of some people already starting the
LeBron talk which is just insane to a
look at the stats crazy but it but like
it's it's that Jordan's the best player
of all time I can wear the shoes of the
best player of all time that he wore
while he was being the best player of
all time it's so simple I can buy I can
buy it's like Tiger Woods doesn't even
go by the same clubs that Tiger Woods
supposedly uses but you're not using the
same clubs his are made different right
but you Jordan sneakers or jordan
sneakers you go buy them by the same
socks that's the craziest thing is like
I used to when you bought those as a kid
you bought in the play if you were a
basketball player meaning play in the
park like yeah you get you wanted you I
would wear them to play and I will come
home and scrub the [ __ ] out of this I
can wear them to the party yeah you know
like they were doing double time for you
they were everything oh speaking of
which do you have like a certain brand
of shoe white shoe cleaner that you like
and that works yes it actually works it
actually works and you know what I don't
know the name my girlfriend bought it
for me uh forget where she got it and
they actually have a brush on the top
okay um I could try and see if she could
get all texts and get me the name I
don't even know the name but they are
yeah let me know cuz i have a couple
pairs of white shoes i want to clean and
i don't want to waste there's a lot of
good products out there too but i'll get
you the out i'll tackle of the night
like nicekicks would have a good for
sure that's the trouble yeah yeah just
yeah but I'll get you the 1i got but
yeah like you you played in it like when
jordan 5s came out which are like the
real high tops yeah since the since tues
i guess but i never [ __ ] with tubes
but they were like my era the fur like
they were higher than tues two threes in
the wars or quarters yeah you know I was
right like i laced those up when right
you know the white ones with the 23 with
the black tongue yeah and then the
reflective great song i was playing in
those can't wait to go home put on my
Jordans I'm not even gonna go do
anything today we gonna walk around my
shopping be careful walking around
though you get bad posture if you stare
at
well I know I catch my not as much as
you do I don't think but I do that when
I get a new parishes I'll just [ __ ]
stare them when I'm walking down the
street or if I'm sitting there like with
my leg just like look at them um how do
we feel about and I'm not trying to make
this until I can issue this is a
question like for me I think it's hot as
[ __ ] why seeing a girl in some bald a
yummy yeah it's like when you see a girl
driving like an old pickup truck that is
now the pickup truck and was weird girl
and how do i marry her a girl in a man's
Rolex all day so you're saying if a girl
rolled up an old beat-up pickup truck
with a [ __ ] it's very subtle like
datejust on her wrist and she hot it's
out with a submariner on her wrist just
a man-sized Rolex and hot word out and
is wearing some grape fives you're just
like hey girl I'm not gonna lie yeah hey
girl drop in the world my girl does that
i've got i've convinced so many my
female friends to buy cool sneakers
because I'm just like a you look cool
[ __ ] and it's it's it'll be this bizarre
trigger to every dude around like oh
[ __ ] she's cool is it she's fun yet not
gonna like it's not even like sections
like oh [ __ ] she's cool I went out on a
limb for my girlfriend and I was like
first Christmas but like we hadn't been
together that long you had at you had a
tough timing of Christmas i remember
right we were in a weird moment it's
like we start dating someone a month
before Valentine's that you're like we
are what do i do together for like a
year but i think it was sick but it was
it was a few months yeah but we it was a
good few months like we you know a
whirlwind if you were little hoorah I
was this on the fence and she always
liked said and commented on like my some
of my sneakers and like always like said
like that like she noticed that right
away with me so I just went out I mean I
got her some other stuff but I went out
on the limb I gather a pair of Chicago
ones which is just like the starter kit
Jordon yeah they are incredibly classic
right this is like the start I told you
I was gonna and my embargo yes thank you
I was like I was like Chicago
get your feet wet quote unquote lack of
a phrase yeah so I got a pair of jordan
ones and I got her a pair of grape 5s
white grape vines which are like to me a
very cool shoe for a woman they got the
purple tongue yeah just like they're
white they're cute as [ __ ] and the kind
of what also two fives are kind of bulky
so she's a size five and a half so I all
my foot was small I wear fives a lot and
they look good but they look big the
tongue is big and bold fives on a girl
look dang well on a small foot look
[ __ ] yeah but there is a side effect
that comes with this Nick and Kevin
uh-huh so I get now she's now she got
like four pairs of jordans now at this
point she wear that was like your guys's
first i would say couple instagram shot
across the bow yes two pairs of math you
guys got matching Jordans you had you
had fives all so I believe we titled the
Instagram Jordans be flirtin flirtin it
was her great vibes and mice and men
well maybe my true blue three yeah and
it was like guess what guys these two
are in a couple alright but here's the
downside to that Nick and Kevin so you
laced your girl up you put her on the
jersey kind of it this is like a part of
culture you shoulda not saying we're him
every day but have a pair of two yeah
and then she wears them out one day and
then all that is is a smoke signal for
dudes yeah to stare at your girl to be
like oh I'm out so I've been walking
with her when she's wearing the Chicago
ones and near the original Chicago ones
and like guys cat call her for she's a
very pretty girl my mistake she's my
girl like you notice her she's cute
she's beautiful and then they see the
sneakers and got while I'm walking with
her hand in hand they owe you a [ __ ]
yeah oh [ __ ] look at you like just
screaming at about my phone into a fight
over this wow it's a it's a it's a it's
sonar have you gotten your lady pair of
jordans and love sneakers at all now
gotta change ever you know how she's
probably trying to change you right now
because she's a woman that's what they
do you got to change her a little bit
you gotta get into some sneakers that's
right you know it's the only thing she's
trying to use me
my house cleaner which was valid does
she work out yes what is she wearing she
wears nike runners like nike running
shoes like you know the ones like the
black of the white soul like some
generic running yeah we haven't even
talked about air max oh [ __ ] I got a few
pairs of those do you oh yeah you dear
max I'm obsessed with my denim ones
yellow and black one I have a whole set
infrared am I remember the other one
that's my for I took my friend Cassandra
because she a new job in a writers room
and I was like get cool sneakers
everyone will think you're cool and she
got air max their lawyer that thing you
again on the air max have a huge read
like air max you can get a full loggers
got the pink black boys love them
because i am a shorter gentlemen air max
give you a little boost is a little
she'll if you really look there's a
little heel to an air max I got about
about another half an inch of height I
propelled a five foot seven and a half
on where max rights finally got Nick
don't have that problem no nothing
jordans would work for micro I think hi
top vans would like you was so good just
get a repair Jordans man yeah there's a
different look to that like a high top
fans versus like a pair of Nikes it's
very it's very it's different yeah it's
a little like sporty-er and kind of like
it just someone looks more a girl would
just look more fun in a pair of Nikes
instead of like vans for somebody III
disagree i think it's different kind of
fun like a cool pair of high top bands
i'm like sporty or fun we s Sporting ya
like like fans is like your chill your
laid-back a cool ones like more indie
rock ones like more remember i bought
the pair like denim vans and realize
that you can't wear them with any g
never i didn't buy canadian i just saw a
pair of denim is like these are [ __ ]
kind of gray I love them and I bought
them and I'm just not a short guy like
I'm likes like like I wear like
basketball shorts obviously but I don't
have any kind of like short to wear to
like a day party I just I've never had I
tried to force vans on you so hard it
did not stay take you and 00 Vince no no
I have like four pair a four pair of
vans wearing voice yeah I wear them
twice a year um I know
these white vans haven't won in a while
yeah I tried to force them on you didn't
stick didn't take you done wonders with
me on certain things are you back with
air force ones at all no really well cuz
i was told and this is an awful thing i
was told and I don't even know this but
while in like the height of entourage
and some of my heavier days when I was
above the two bills category um right
around the time sb's became really
popular again like the SB resurgent you
know someone from like hot rod in
westwood came like i want to gift you
these pair black by gifting I wore them
on the show right so I earn those and
then one of the other people there was
like yeah you got stopped at the air
force ones those are fat kid shoes yeah
house I what we taught [ __ ] you talking
about I mean look around everyone like
each other that they were dubbed at some
point fat chubby kid shoe does that
cause a fat joe I'm no idea that even
mean really [ __ ] isn't fat the person
in my idol force one song the first look
that up right now the person who said
that to me who will remain nameless uh
just spit simple that's like his view
that wasn't like a pop culture of you
but at the time I didn't know any better
nice guy and by the way the sb's I got
handed were amazing shows how
impressionable I am it's very it's very
low it is very easy to pick picture a
overweight East Coast type it by duty
well they look no no jean jean shorts
very big jean shorts with white Air
Force One jean shorts why efforts on air
force ones because they're wide you look
good with baggy or jeans as well right
jordans don't look the best with baggy
jeans and sb's not ESPYs actually do too
but that was like more like skinny
skater yes Aggie Jean there's nothing on
here about a fat kid airport I call that
spit in the beam which means you're
bullshitting and I fell for it yeah I
hot rods a great store by the way I
right yeah yeah I haven't been there and
I got all my vans from there hi rod
westwood is right by the fats at like
when fat sal's first opened up i would
go over there and like we were still
figuring it out and I would eat and like
yeah like be waiting for a Sal or Josh
to combine then just go to the hot rod
yeah kick it that's a cool show yeah if
you had to pay
one Jordan that you could only wear for
the rest of your life what would it be
that's hard classic color color scheme
to who they asked me to pick between
children yeah how about this i give you
two color schemes the same model all
right look I I the pic is officers dia
but there's definitely a cooler answer
but if that were I'm just taking that as
little as possible you're telling me
that is fact the rest of my life that is
it yeah it's white cement 3s in black
cement 3 that's Annie and that's it but
there are way cooler like in terms of
like there are a lot cooler ways to go
think you can I love laney 5s are
[ __ ] amazing do anywhere go white and
black three four or five because they
all although the thing is for me ones I
don't where might the kind of pants I
wear ones like my pants will fit over
the top of one's right which is still a
good look it's not I don't do that I
don't do the genes into the tongue thing
it's a tough thing to pull up I still
haven't mastered it all the time like I
I'd like it you could do it with threes
and fives easily like the tongue is so
dominant yeah that it's not that
distracting but once that's why I never
wore my three of you know Elevens like
this like Elevens the tongue goes oh
like your jeans could go over pretty
well and they don't look like a cool
shoe yeah yeah I I go look the more I
look at those a cooler they are f1 of by
the way you're gonna set their little
Spacely be careful you're wearing raw
denim they will leave a blue ring or on
top I told you I'm not gonna be precious
underway yeah I can't be Precious about
I'll turn to cycle the blue will just
match the shoe yeah I guess the dead the
denim will like so you go threes white
and black right like that like if you if
I'm taking that in the literal sense and
not being creative at all I would go
that direction but the back it's that's
the real Ray rubber piece in the back
that where it says nike air you know
what the best and Nick if you wanna
google is just to see like what I think
is a very good shoe to wait like just in
terms of like you could wear that you
could dress up a little bit and wear
them and still be like no one will think
you're a child by seeing that you're
wearing sneakers is green
low force griga wear green glow fours as
like an accessory to a dope button-down
rolled-up sleeves a nice watch a nice
pair of [ __ ] jeans and like you you
stated say they actually are like a
conversation piece they're pretty rare
Jordan's have become green blow their
[ __ ] cool they become kind where the
decibel thing to wear I know I mean
they're very popular right now I notice
with agents like young agents type dudes
young Hollywood people like a deck what
is it generation act what do we not
there why they're one hour XO do we
talking people that would be Generation
Y to wear with like a button down and a
[ __ ] nice jeans and then you have
George respectable jessica Lee my outfit
for any business meeting i have is also
comedians there's like alternative
comedians have began begun really yeah
fetishize please check out sneakers of
every comedian on stage and I'm yet to
like air maxs I've noticed every time I
never see Jordan sem everybody watches a
couple of times I see Jordan one's a lot
on comics you know who owns a ton air
maxs D'Elia krystalya yeah he owes a
chili is a big sneaker head he has a lot
of Jordan ones too yeah he's big on a
hill fine like two pairs two types of
shoes he loves and then just get 50
years I think Kevin you need to go buy a
pair of just get so I think you get
Chicago one start there Nick I see green
glows in Chicago ones I would wear those
I didn't find any Chicago ones for less
than like four hundred dollars I have
the only pair up now or I think they're
fives right to jordans the White Sox
ones no those are Jordan ones white sox
edition no no they're not once are you
sure positive all right I think there
once I don't think so you look at the
one shape fives you know the fives are
completely different shirt and the
payment that they had the pinstripes on
yeah those are ones i hear once yeah
sure see I looked for Chicago fives and
they were all look just like to I I
don't want to spend well I was gonna
bring you a pair just a try on too
because I said like the tongue over the
fives uh I was gonna actually give you
like hang on to these where I'm see like
them i think i have a that's a couple of
tens like just too i don't know if
that's the right shoe for you that's
be there I'm not sure my pants will fit
over the tongue of the phone they won't
yeah they totally are definitely you got
it you are ones threes uh tens 11 I'm
willing I go one or three what about
tues or tues really smoking I just
choose went over my life force whose are
a weird choice that's kind of why I like
them choose of the milgauss of Jordan
serious like I don't know if they sold
and I think they actually did sell back
in a day but I I I just wasn't they
don't look like Jordans to me I don't
know why something in is there that's a
part of me like some is there they're
like this weird anomaly Jordan yeah
they're cool and they have the they say
air jordan on him so you know like fours
and fives at all no i do i love for 4cs
I mean three four and five or [ __ ]
fours are much more like my generation
of like I think the first Jordan I ever
played in what will work for us yeah
I've said that before on the podcast one
of the reasons the jordan 1 means so
much to me is half the bones brigade
wears them in the bin the movie I mean
tommy guerrero Steve Caballero Lance
mountain I believe Mike McGill I don't
know what kind of shoes tony hawks why
are we not gonna go sneaker shopping
after this podcast guys like in disgust
ago i don't know if i see a way around
it I will totally go I i wanted to
mention airwalks just briefly because
that was a shoe i fed oh yeah those were
cool Tony Hawk had a pair of white air
walks with a big velcro strap and my dad
wouldn't plan four weeks there were 50
bucks I want him so bad they were so
weird looking we're so cool those were
great and then I got a pair of vision
sneakers that were great not the hot not
the skinny item was they made like a
bulky one that was like an air walk they
were but like I fetishized half cabs
Jordan ones those white airwalks of Tony
Hawk had after that I pair of Carl can I
boots cool to me those are cool to me
and then it but then from then as far as
negras goes in timberlands no that was
not a West Coast thing at all yeah cuz
that's like a new East Coker
i knows it was just not where we are I
in some timberlands now that was that
was it that temple store in the mall
where you just see like dudes walking
out like yeah yeah with these junior
prom I got a suit and my mom bought me
party I crawl can I boots I didn't want
to buy we're like dress shoes so my suit
pants fit over Carl can I were brown
leather boots and I was like I was about
as cool to get my line cuz it a big like
metal plate this year I'll compile
decide I recently try i have a big daddy
kane worm i had parody a green bean
fives to agreement which are very cool
sneaker and I was gonna but they got
beat up and I'm like you know what they
were kind of like imma try and play in
them right like wearing [ __ ] ankle
weights yeah it's like out Michael
Jordan was able to defy gravity well you
know what I love now of the new ones cuz
that's think sneaker there's so much
lighter now so I like by like seventy
percent the kds the KD 2 well now you're
talking to like the whole and again this
is like me China grandpa like you love
the easy money kds that I had yeah strap
[ __ ] love those shoes they're so cool
looking there's something about my eye
that play basketball to three times a
week and I it was so weird Kobe Bryant
introduced like the low tops into the
game and then followed by the CP threes
and then Durant and I was so scared for
so long to wear low tops playing hoops
it just seems scientifically your
breaker an incorrect right and I
sprained my ankle bad wearing like
high-top LeBrons like rear and it did
nothing for me I said [ __ ] so when I
healed up I started wearing Kobe's I
mean they weigh an ounce yeah I ran
faster jump [ __ ] I was definitely more
athletic wear and we could of course
talking limited athleticism at 35 years
old and I start wearing durants like now
I'm all like I'm only low tops when I
play like I'll occasionally where I have
like pair of high top Carmelo's which I
don't love because there are high tops
now uncomfortable to play basketball in
for me right like it's Kobe's its
Durant's it's cp3 is the only thing
because
I just like the low to mid level I have
no idea how to how I would wear Durant's
like you kinda can't wear with pants the
strap makes it real difficult like real
weird and the way the bag pops out is
weird but like I saw a guy at the gym
wearing I'm which shorts and they're
just so ridiculous looking they're great
to me yep and some of the color schemes
are great Kevin let's go you you got
dobro man who sponsored this podcast I
know it's not shoe palace we should get
shoe palace podcast for free pair of
Jordans you give us a pair of Jordans
you guys will run ads for the month of
August how would you do that what do two
months short ins go on yeah I would do
two months for a pair easily let's go
shopping girl call cost repels do yeah
we're coming over so hard Sneaky's a
sneak it speakers they get your own it
they triggered the child that the kid in
the kitty heart for sure i could buy a
pair of sneakers and also we're in a
sneaker renaissance because you can buy
every pair you've ever had and all these
new crazy pairs and you can restore
pairs i can buy a good news here is now
every single day and find a cool pair
every day the restoration part of the
sneaker glands are great i'm excited
about that that's like probably the
coolest a peep my friends company keep
is makes great sneakers are so many
great sneakers in the world yeah i want
to get mine restored to like-new you you
could do it I just Ana feelings but I
found the picture of like the brand new
the White Sox ones and I'm like they're
so bright there was no right they are
ones yeah I want admission is how long
sensitive even look like I hid them away
because I was like I don't want to wear
him any more than my only that my first
ones my only ones i put them in a box
and just hid them and i forgot what they
look like the best seeing a brand new
it's like I gotta get him to look like
that again I think I sort of clowns
sneakerheads in my in my mind for a
little while just like that's lame in
the lining up but now that there's
something about it it's like sweet and
like I thought all language like
harmless really no one's get really
getting killed for them anymore like
it's a thing you're into it's not super
expensive it's just like they're just
shoes you can be when you like trying by
the ones that are available on eBay
on them kids but they're not kids you
know those young young guys at the party
let were just fine like do you hear them
speak about it it's almost like wow you
put that much effort into other things
in your life you're gonna be all right
for the day I get it or not it is our
expert now it is designed it is like
learning it's an ability to go out and
do research you're right you're saying
like these dudes are gonna be all right
like if you went to Florence Italy and
went to go study art in the same way you
study sneakers like you could you could
be an art major like you could learn a
lot about Renaissance art well that's in
the same way lots of famous graffiti
artists became great artists are great
designers and stuff it's just the
ability to be passionate and get fired
up about something so yeah to know
what's good cavite [ __ ] that could be a
whole other thing I could be a whole
other thing but wearing Jordans while
doing graffiti quickly about the BB the
famous West Coast rafidi artists risk
just put out a really good book so go
buy that you love buzz one and I don't
know about famous like graffiti ours in
the bronze a great book i'll give you a
bow okay do it from bronx or New York
people and Lee is a big one that's
that's one I know of that's why I did
like I'm not trying it like I really do
feel like the coolest part of America is
like the differences in culture from
east coast to west CO yeah it really is
a war with a faint there's a hole to use
the famous graffiti artists here are
different you know that famous graffiti
artists here or mere skate hex was big
risk the seventh letter crew those guys
and you know that and then but then you
go up to san francisco and you get you
get barry mcgee shepard fairey kind of
transcends different coasts but yeah
it's I kind of like that where it's each
area has their famous people all right I
really think your crew I think both of
you need to in the relatively near
future buy yourself a pair of Jordans
Kevin specifically you really knew
really need to only because you've been
a hypocrite all this time I think you
know it I'm just nike jordan i don't
know nike [ __ ] haha you owe yourself
something i carrying him back into a
hypocrite I don't know
ki [ __ ] okay hey come see my friend Neil
Brennan's nike courses they're super
funny and also I don't support nike at
all no no no I support Nikes uh the
choice in TV directors I'll I now your
art your starter back slightly already
get back to where you were loud I like I
[ __ ] that I've told you what i like
about nike i like that they were the
first major company to put a black
athlete is the face of their company I
like they pay skateboards a lot of money
like they hire Neil and they have they
are good designers you like their shoes
just say that now you can we spent 90
minutes talking about you they're
incredible designs and I like the other
would ever get a pair for your girl I
don't think I'd wear thick she where
that came from you I think she wear like
once and then I'd see a manor house a
lot get a pair of black so you know what
one if she's in a comfortable shoes
shall wear more because they are [ __ ]
comfortable ok button women will for
comfort for the sake of what I mean they
wear high heels that's I mean but maybe
I don't make every now and then now she
has other shoes that she doesn't wear
that she wears could to be comfortable
that are she has like converse all-stars
okay oh yeah that's like that's right
down the street that's right around the
corner not from Air Jordans is not
pretty comfortable there's some girls
that just don't wear sneakers I congress
also i fell asleep but i think the next
step for would be like vans I don't
think you're only she did cultural
differences yeah where she from again
from here I she could do high tops
because she has long legs haha so
there's not like a risk of like oh
they'll make it ones I think it get over
the fear of like oh she might know and
just go for just bill can't dudes gonna
look at her on the street yeah dude
alright natural way from you all right
all right we're gonna do okay you're
right it the pack I knew you would
completely completely flip out every day
yeah sneaker name it's awesome this
makes me feel like a like a herb
throwback to an earlier part episode of
her to get a pair of high tops and lay
some up way too tight like this before
look at this [ __ ] horrible via
his [ __ ] snake is bro look at this
[ __ ] Oh y'all your [ __ ] choke in
this [ __ ] out of the [ __ ] sneaky
[ __ ] herb because you know may have
said that exact dialogue at one point we
know you when you when you lace up
sneakers too tight and then there's a
little dirt involve you get those weird
marks right by the holes you get those
[ __ ] lines outside on the outside of
this other lace was your accent that
heavy when you moved out I was wet you
know what's happened to me it's bizarre
and ironic I've lived in LA for 15 years
I now have a fake New York is a little
bit in there when you talk now when you
were doing that impression I was like
wow it like takes work to do that and I
don't know if it's a hundred percent
accurate anymore you've been working on
your non-regional diction like receiving
election by Christian Apple no I mean
it's still there with certain words and
like when I get heated but like they
having my friend here from Brooklyn like
it's not sneakers sneakers but when you
get when you get mad like over yelling
early we don't have the money no insect
babe no honestly I don't really want to
go to that restaurant tonight because I
just don't want to eat there I said I
don't want to [ __ ] go at dinner over
there well like I did it comes back yeah
all the arse disappear oh my mom
something special her accent something
special it's so I I like make fun of her
now actually start to feel bad like wow
hers is something special nice turlet mr
lees ter loi to charlotte territorial
it's not working ok what's book and I'll
close with that one the turlet is not
working the turtle let's know that's
maybe the episode all right thank thanks
again for doing this dude anytime I'm a
big fan of the occasionally awesome
podcast we're a big fan of you being our
dynasty gust all right that's the closer
right there boomba three-peat I finally
get a star on some walk of fame in my
own right nike we're not ending with
that we're ending with kevin's getting a
pair of jordans weather like this
tattooed on your tricep oh
I like when people get the swoosh
tattooed on their foot as a joke that's
funny that actually is pretty funny yeah
okay okay we'll see you guys next week
see you guys next week see you guys next
week see you guys next week see you guys
next week see you guys next week see you
guys next week see you guys next week
see you guys next week see you guys next
week see you guys next week see